[Musique]
ger artisans et futurs artisans les élus
de cette nouvelle mandature se joignent
à moi pour vous remercier de la
confiance que vous nous accordez pour
défendre vos intérêts l'année 2000 21
est derrière nous entrons dans l'année
2022 avec optimisme et détermination
pour mener à bien nos projets au
quotidien nombreux sont les défis qui
nous attendent en tant que créateurs et
dirigeants d'entreprise il nous faut
gérer notre activité s'adapter aux
nouveaux modes de consommation
innover pour être plus compétitif
stabiliser nos emplois former nos
apprentis accélérer la transition
numérique est écologique et faire face
aux obstacles financiers pour tous ses
projets les équipes et les élus de la
chambre de métiers de l'artisanat vous
accompagne dans toutes les étapes de la
vie de votre entreprise de sa création à
sa transmission spécialiste de la
création d'entreprise l'acm à vous
accompagne et vous forme pour conduire
votre projet sur la voie du succès vos
démarches administratives sont
simplifiées
digitaliser et peuvent même est prise en
charge par un conseiller consacrez vous
à l'essentiel le lancement de notre
activité l'acm à développe des services
innovants centrés sur vos besoins pour
vous permettre d'optimiser votre
savoir-faire stratégie commerciale
innovation développement durable
financement investissement ressources
humaines quelle que soit votre activité
et votre lieu d'exercice lass et emma et
notre interlocuteur de proximité de la
gestion à la comptabilité en passant par
le développement commercial et digital
le juridique rouen caen la bureautique
l'offre de formation de la sema et
adapté à vos activités et à leurs
évolutions montée en compétences avec le
centre de formation de la sema nous
sommes une équipe de femmes et d'hommes
réunis autour des mêmes valeurs porteur
des mêmes convictions est engagé dans un
projet partagé celui de défendre
accompagner et valoriser les entreprises
artisanales l'histoire en 2022 pour
accélérer votre réussite poussez la
porte de votre cm à votre réussite et
notre ambition belles années artisanale
[Musique]